[Musique]
eric zemmour possible le candidat à la
présidentielle parce que le csa demande
désormais aux médias un décompte de son
temps de parole oui parce qu'il le
considère je cite comme un acteur du
débat politique national on voit que le
cese ca est en train de torturer la loi
pour décompter le temps pour ajouter un
temps de parole et eric simon alors même
qu'on n'est pas en campagne électorale
pourquoi et alors même qu'il n'est pas
encore candidat et pas d'égalité mais de
les quitter c'est en fonction en partie
du résultat des dernières élections du
poids politique donc comme eric zemmour
n'a pas de parti il sera rangé dans la
catégorie divers droite si zemmour
explose les compteurs la chaîne pour à
rééquilibrer le temps de parole avec les
autres candidats qu'est ce qui pose
problème avec eric zemmour mékong avec
votre chaîne généralement c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya un certain nombre de
gens gros qui sont à droite et qui n'ont
pas honte de le dire mais attendez
jusqu'à présent les éditorialistes
j'entendais sur tout un tas d'autres
médias je veux dire si sur france inter
ils sont pas de gauche si le csa veut
être cohérent il faut qu'il comptabilise
le temps de parole de tous ces gens
parce que sinon moi j'ai le droit à ma
liberté d'expression qui est garantie
par ma carte de presse 57 cents je tiens
à le préciser il utilise le haut on sait
très bien ce que c'est que le ont ils
dit j'ai la joie d'apprendre à 19 heures
pour les seuils de me faire taire mais
c'est qui ce qu'après un moment où il
faut arrêter de dire on essaye de me
faire taire qui les politiques sont
tellement lâche qu'il se cache derrière
un organisme soit disant indépendants
qui n'est absolument pas indépendant et
qui est soumis vous l'avez dit vous-même
à toutes les pressions les pressions de
qui de gens dans marche en marche c'est
qui c'est le gouvernement et le
gouvernement sait qui c'est emmanuel
macron vous accusez mais bien sûr que
j'accuse c'est peut-être les
institutions est ce que c'est le
gouvernement c'est l'émoi à mes yeux
eric zemmour ce n'est pas un délinquant
un pur jeu j'emploie ce terme là parce
qu'un arrière il a été de délinquants
non mais ils disent qu'il n'est des
gains politiques je peux vous annoncer
d'ailleurs que la contraception sera
désormais gratuite pour toutes les
femmes âgées jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans
c'est à dire qu'il y aura une prise en
charge la contraception hormonale
en biologique qui peut aller avec de la
consultation de prescription et de tous
les soins qui sont liées à cette
contraception
les riverains ont beau vociférer leur
message s'envole dans le vide
sur le pont de la rue riquet un
campement d'environ 200 consommateurs de
crack s'est progressivement installée là
où il est je suis sûr et certain qu'il
sourit comme toujours et qu'il est
pleinement heureux de cet hommage
heureux aussi de voir à quel point les
français elle témoigne de leur amour
lüthi les émettant depuis leur
évacuation des jardins d'eole le 30 juin
dernier les toxicomanes sont livrés à
eux mêmes y déambule l'air hagard devant
les yeux pleins de colère des passants
la gueule que l'on voulait voir dans les
salles obscures
la gouaille qui réchauffe et les soirées
télévisées des français
belmondo
fut la figure qui transperça les styles
traversa les époques casse à toutes les
barrières et l'image des états unis le
déboulonnage en virginie d'un symbole
majeur du passé esclavagiste de la
meriva l'occurrence la gigantesque
statue du général lee les automobilistes
pris au piège sont contraintes
d'abandonner leur voiture ce scooter n'a
pas d'autre choix que de rebrousser
chemin les rues d'agen sont tout
simplement devenus des rivières dans les
points bas de la ville l'eau est montée
jusqu'à 1 m 82 auteur la statue de
bronze était une oeuvre de l'artiste
français antonin mercié
dans la cour des invalides
c'est la musique du film le
professionnels composés par ennio
morricone qui accompagne le départ que
jean paul belmondo
[Musique]